hey everybody I'm CeCe and the most
interesting thing that I learned this
year was that if you give me a good
enough story that has enough interesting
parts I can be motivated to do things
that I used to absolutely loathe for
example running so ever since I was a
little girl I just I hated running for
two reasons first sweating is gross and
second I can't really bored right so
when I tried running as a little kid I
would spend the entire run thinking
about how miserable I was that I decided
to run doesn't work out very well
now as I got older I tried again and
again because you know I've heard about
the runner's high it's so great and the
exercise is great then eventually came
with you know the conclusion that I need
to assure myself this won't work but
about a month ago I started playing a
game
it's very aptly named Zombies Run which
is kind of cool right the game itself is
just an iPhone game and I don't think
that the slide is going to advance
anymore but essentially what happens is
now I run about three or four times a
week and two miles a day right so that's
kind of crazy and I don't know that I
quite grasp that this is happening but
the way it works is through sort of a
motivational story all they really do is
they take together audio files and they
mix it in with your own music and
suddenly when you push play you become
the main character in a zombie
apocalypse story okay now to give you
guys sort of the full experience I've
decided that I'm gonna reenact the
beginning of episode 2 for you now I
first have to catch you up with what
happened in episode 1 so imagine you're
on a helicopter and you're flying to
this town to give them supplies when all
of a sudden somebody shoots a rocket
launcher at you and your helicopter goes
down right so you parachute out you get
on the ground you know there are zombies
around here and you book it now someone
is talking to you on your headset you
don't know who he claims he's from the
town but he doesn't know if you're alive
or dead he's just talking and that's
when the episode starts so this is
really where I invite you to sort of
close your eyes if you wish and listen
pretend like you're running and my voice
is in your headphones Wow there's
someone alive down there hey hey can you
can you hear me
no answer still look at him go heading
for that tower just like I said okay
running person if you can hear me you're
doing really great the main pack is
behind you and you're gonna come out of
this forest really soon but there's a
well I can't think of a better phrase
than small army of zombies coming to get
you I don't do very well under massive
pressure but that's okay you're gonna be
okay if you just head towards that large
building to your left everything will be
okay hey look look at that there
changing directions
oh my god they get you you can hear me
okay okay great
it's cool we're gonna get you safe we're
gonna bring you in and no we are not
gonna ask them that question because
they might be injured all of the more
reason to ask them that question listen
my name is dr. Abel and I'm the medic
here the only medic at Abel Township
your path is going to take you almost to
the old hospital and we know there are
medicates there from the first wave of
infection if you could pick up just one
or two that would help us but it's too
dangerous you know what happened to
runner five all of the zoms are headed
towards the site of the crash but what
about whoever fired that rocket launcher
listen if someone is gonna kill that
runner taking an unusual route will make
it harder not easier I don't want to be
hard-headed but everyone in this
Township earns their keep you should be
able to see the hospital by now if you
get there and you can't find anything we
might not be able to let you in when you
get here so that's the beginning of
episode two it's pretty great the game
sort of takes you through some twists
and turns that are plot to like not plot
devices but they're very interesting
because the danger is never the same
it's not always zombies running after
you what's happening sometimes is let's
say hey I have a running partner now she
doesn't believe me
she doesn't believe that I got off that
helicopter and then I sort of you know
killed somebody took their clothes and
then came to this town that's dangerous
um or you know you're running through
the woods you hear a child crying you
know the zombies are gonna get them you
want to get to that kid first so what's
really cool and what really sticks with
me about this game is how much my
survival instinct really just like kicks
in even though all
other sensory perceptions are telling me
otherwise so let me just paint this
picture for you sometimes I like to run
at night in a gym on a treadmill right
and you know I get there I push play I'm
on our treadmill I know for a fact there
are no zombies in this gym now I see the
TV screen in front of me it is always a
cooking show that I always cannot figure
out how to turn off it tonight so the
window sort of reflect me back to me so
I see myself running on a treadmill
right I have my gym shorts my headphones
my iPhone in my hand because that's how
I do it and all of a sudden you get to
that point in the story in which there's
some groaning and some moaning and it
gets louder and the danger is totally
there and even though my very logical
mind is telling me there is no way
there's any zombies in this gym I feel
that urge to run faster because I have
to and I do and I do it over and over
again thank you
[Applause]